nicholas caser how are you
i'm very well thank you how are you
i'm doing great man look this movie is
for your fans it's like a celebration
of everything you your performances your
movies but for you
when you got to play in nicholas cage
what was it like to be able to put in
your performance just like
greatest hits of your own performance
references
well it was
you know i'm gonna be completely direct
with you it was weird i mean to play
myself in a movie
was the
strangest and scariest thing i've ever
done in 43 years of being a film actor i
i
i had the combination of trying to
facilitate the director's vision of
so-called nic cage and also trying to
protect whoever
nic cage is in my own life and so that
was a balancing act but
i think that collision was good for the
movie and i think it brought
um a lot of
laughter for
anyone who goes to the theater i think
you will enjoy the show because
everybody's laughing together and so i'm
happy i did it
what was it like seeing you
face to face with your like younger wild
at heart
version of yourself yeah well it was
certainly my my uh presentation on the
wogan show i went on that show back in
the 80s when i was promoting wild at
heart and that guy was obnoxious he was
arrogant he was irreverent i thought he
was the perfect model to play nicki the
younger version of myself in this movie
and those were my favorite scenes in the
movie in fact they were my favorite
scenes when i read the script and
largely why i made the movie i liked
those scenes and uh i had so much fun
doing those scenes in the film
have you or have you not actually seen
paddington two
i have seen paddington too and that was
one of the happy takeaways from this
experience it's a great movie very
poignant and a lot of fun and uh
those are some of my favorite
conversations in the movie with uh
pedro's character javi suggesting
paddington two and my character
suggesting the very avant-garde cabinet
of dr caligari two movies that couldn't
be more
diametrically opposed and yet two movies
that are uh
are both excellent films
um one of the themes that i love that
runs through this
that you know is underneath the talk
about you know the favorite nick cage
movies is just the idea of movies
bringing people together
in general is that one of the things
that you loved about doing this as well
i think so and i i think that's a great
observation and why i would recommend
seeing this movie in the cinema because
it's been a long time and we all need to
laugh right now and i saw it in the
cinema and people were having so much
fun it was almost like an electric
energy in the in the theater and i
recommend seeing this particular movie
in the theater it's a very communal
experience
right on man thank you so much for the
time and it was i saw it in the theater
too with with a bunch of people and it
was a blast
oh that's good news thank you
you